vamos a hablar de una técnica muy
poderosa para hacer análisis de
circuitos y esa técnica es el método de
voltaje de nodos también conocida como
análisis de nodos o método de tensiones
novales ahora antes de empezar a hablar
acerca de este método tan poderoso
primero tenemos que hablar acerca de un
término que no hemos visto que es el
voltaje de un nodo hasta ahorita hemos
hablado acerca del voltaje de algunos
elementos por ejemplo podemos tener un
resistor y sabemos que tiene un voltaje
al que por cierto también le podemos
llamar la diferencia de potencial y en
ese caso nos estamos refiriendo a la
diferencia de potencial entre sus dos
extremos pero bueno en estos casos
estamos hablando acerca del voltaje de
un elemento o si en lugar de estar
hablando acerca de un solo elemento
estamos hablando acerca de toda una rama
podemos hablar acerca del voltaje de
toda esa rama
alta g de rama y es un voltaje asociado
directamente con el elemento o rama
ahora por otro lado también podemos
tener este otro nuevo concepto de
voltaje de un nodo voltaje de nodo sigue
siendo un voltaje no es nada extraño
pero ahora vayamos al circuito y
empecemos a ponerle nombres a nuestros
nodos por aquí a este nuevo de aquí
entre la fuente de voltaje y este
resistor la unión entre estos dos le
vamos a llamar el nodo 1 por aquí
tenemos otro nodo que es la unión entre
estos dos resistor es y esta fuente de
corriente todo esto de aquí es un solo
no lo distribuido y vamos a decir que es
el nodo 2 y finalmente estos tres
componentes están unidos por un solo
nodo distribuido al cual le vamos a
llamar 3
para poder definir los voltajes de los
nodos lo primero que tenemos que hacer
es escoger un nuevo de referencia nodo
de referencia y es bastante importante
es [ __ ] un buen novo de referencia
ahora los buenos nuevos de referencia
son los que están conectados a las
fuentes o los que están conectados a
muchísimos elementos y por aquí en este
circuito el nodo 3 es un muy buen novo
de referencia y la forma de denotar que
estamos escogiendo a éste como el nodo
de referencia es poniendo por aquí un
símbolo como este el símbolo de tierra
estamos diciendo que el nodo 3 es
nuestra tierra también hay otras formas
de indicar que un nodo es nuestro nodo
de referencia esta es una de las formas
de decir que esta es nuestra tierra
también podemos dibujar a la tierra de
esta forma y aquí parecemos como que
tenemos tierra de adeveras y algunas
veces te lo puedes encontrar simplemente
así como un atv acá arriba estas son
nuestras tres formas de indicar cuál es
el
de referencia y aquí nosotros escogimos
que el nuevo de referencia sea el nodo 3
porque es el que más nos conviene así es
que ahora sí vamos a empezar a calcular
los voltajes de nodos y eso se hace
calculando el voltaje de los nodos con
respecto al nodo de referencia entonces
el aumento de voltaje de este punto a
este punto es el voltaje del nodo 1
porque hoy el voltaje de novo del nodo 1
y por eso le llamamos b 1 y luego
también la diferencia de voltaje entre
este punto y este otro punto es el
voltaje del nodo del nodo 2 porque
tomamos la diferencia de voltaje con
respecto al nodo de referencia por aquí
tenemos el menos y el más y el menos
y bueno claro que vamos a utilizar estos
voltajes de nodo en el método de
voltajes de novo pero primero vamos a
poner todo lo que sabemos acerca de este
circuito por ejemplo por aquí tenemos
una fuente de voltaje a su voltaje le
vamos a llamar bs y es de 15 volts este
resistor es r1 y tiene 4.000 ohms de
resistencia y este resistor por aquí le
vamos a llamar r 2 y tiene una
resistencia de 2000 oms este es
exactamente el mismo circuito que
estábamos viendo en otro vídeo hace poco
acerca de la aplicación de las leyes
fundamentales y finalmente esta fuente
de corriente tiene una intensidad iv s
de 3
pérez ya hemos analizado este circuito
anteriormente utilizando las leyes de
kirch para corriente y voltaje el sk y
el beckham además de la ley de ohm y
utilizando esas leyes fundamentales
encontramos todos los voltajes y
corrientes que nos faltaban hicimos todo
el análisis del circuito y ahorita vamos
a hacer exactamente lo mismo encontrar
los voltajes y las corrientes faltantes
pero esta vez utilizando otro método el
método de voltajes de nodos básicamente
es lo mismo estamos aplicando las leyes
fundamentales las leyes de crichton y la
ley de ohm pero con este método lo
hacemos de una forma muy ordenada y muy
eficiente quienquiera que haya inventado
este método era una persona realmente
brillante y le agradezco que haya
compartido su conocimiento con todos
nosotros ahora primero quiero escribir
aquí todos los pasos que vamos a seguir
en este método aunque porque este es un
método no es una teoría
antes tiene una serie de pasos que
seguimos para resolver el circuito vamos
a empezar por aquí el primer paso es
escoger un nuevo de referencia nodo de
referencia y nosotros ya lo escogimos
está por aquí el segundo paso es ponerle
nombre a los voltajes de nodo y también
ya lo hicimos tenemos aquí b1 y b2
voltajes de novos tenemos por aquí ve
uno que es el voltaje del nodo uno con
respecto a nuestro nuevo de referencia
que es el nuevo 3 y por aquí está b 2
que es el voltaje del nodo del nodo 2
con respecto al nodo de referencia y
siempre que estemos hablando acerca de
voltajes de nodos existe la suposición
de que alguno de los nodos del circuito
es el nodo de referencia del cual no
necesitamos calcular su voltaje el
tercer paso es encontrar los voltajes de
nodo fáciles
encontrar los voltajes de los nodos
fáciles y vas a ver en unos cuantos
segundos a qué me refiero con eso pero
primero el paso 4 se trata de escribir
las ecuaciones de la ley de corrientes
de kirchhoff escribir las ecuaciones de
la ley de corrientes de kirchhoff y
finalmente resolver las ecuaciones
resolver ecuaciones si es que aquí
tenemos tal cual el método de voltajes
de nodos ya realizamos los pasos 1 y 2 y
ahora vamos a ver cómo encontrar los
voltajes de nodos fáciles los nodos
fáciles son los que están conectados a
una fuente de voltaje que esté conectada
directamente con el nodo de referencia
bueno por lo menos ese es un ejemplo de
un novo fácil seguramente hay muchos
otros tipos de nodos fáciles porque aquí
nada más observando el circuito ya
sabemos cuánto vale de 1
y esta fuente de voltaje hace un aumento
de 15 volts al nodo de referencia y
llegamos directamente al nodo 1
entonces el voltaje de nodos del nodo 1
v1 tiene que ser igual a 15 volts
entonces ya terminamos con el paso 3
porque el segundo nodo está un poco más
complicado porque tiene estos elementos
que no nos dan tanta información tan
directa así es que repasemos nuevamente
todo lo que ya hemos hecho primero
escogimos un nuevo de referencia este es
el primer paso aquí está nuestro nodo de
referencia el segundo paso es poner los
nombres de los voltajes de nodos por
aquí tenemos los dos voltajes de nodos
que estamos buscando entonces ese es el
paso 2 y finalmente acabamos de resolver
los nodos fáciles
es el paso 3 ahora vamos al paso 4 pero
para eso necesitamos un poquito más de
espacio el paso 4 se trata de escribir
las ecuaciones de la ley de corrientes
de kirchhoff directamente desde nuestro
circuito y vamos a hacer esto de una
forma muy especial vamos a aplicar la
ley de corrientes de kirchhoff en este
nodo de aquí el nodo 2 y para hacer eso
primero tenemos que identificar estas
corrientes
esta es la corriente y 1 porque pasa por
el resistor r 1
esta es la corriente y 2 porque pasa por
el resistor r 2 y esta corriente de aquí
bueno pues esta corriente ya le pusimos
nombre
s así es que por aquí vamos a escribir
la ley de corrientes de kirchhoff en
este nodo sabemos que la ley de
corrientes de kirchhoff nos dice que
todas las corrientes que entran a un
nodo su suma tiene que ser igual a cero
pero por aquí tenemos una corriente que
entra y otras dos corrientes que salen
entonces estas dos corrientes van a
tener un signo negativo lo escribimos
por aquí la ley de corrientes de
kirchhoff para este nodo nos dice que y
uno más menos y dos menos y dos más
menos y ese o sea menos y ese tiene que
ser igual a cero esto es lo que nos dice
la ley de corrientes de kirchhoff en el
nodo 2 y lo que acabamos de hacer aquí
es el paso 4 paso 4
este es el momento en el que vamos a ver
la esencia del método de voltajes por
nodo aquí es donde vamos a hacer las
cosas un poco diferentes
ahora vamos a escribir las corrientes
pero en términos de los voltajes de nodo
porque sabemos por la ley de ohm que una
corriente que pasa por un resistor se
puede escribir como el voltaje en ese
resistor entre su resistencia y el
voltaje en ese resistor lo podemos
calcular a partir de los voltajes del
nodo es b1 b2 b1 menos de dos y luego
dividimos entre la resistencia del
resistor entre la resistencia del
resistor que es 4000 oms pero aquí vamos
a poner r 1 y luego si queremos
encontrar la corriente y 2 ponemos aquí
un menos nos vamos a ir 2 y 2 pasa por
el resistor r 2 entonces calculamos el
voltaje del resistor r 2 el cual es el
voltaje del nodo b 2
2 - el voltaje del nodo 3 pero el nodo 3
es el nodo de referencia entonces su
voltaje nodal su voltaje con respecto a
sí mismo tiene que ser cero así es que
aquí nos queda simplemente b 2 y lo
dividimos entre la resistencia r 2
2 y luego simplemente restamos y ese y
la ley de corrientes de kirchhoff nos
dice que toda esta suma tiene que ser
igual a 0 y listo ya terminamos con el
paso 4 ya escribimos la ecuación que nos
da la ley de corrientes de kurtzio pero
con la anotación de los voltajes de
nodos y ya lo único que falta es
resolver estas ecuaciones lo cual va a
ser muy sencillo ya después con estas
podemos calcular muy fácilmente todos
los voltajes y corrientes